what's going on reject nation we have
made it here to the cobra kai
season 3 finale been quite a
journey guys if you enjoy our reaction
please go ahead hit the like button and
sure does help out the algorithm and i
know i've been plugging our patreon page
at the top of every one of these
reactions i do want to
take a side step to say thank you thank
you thank you to everyone who has shown
your support by joining our patreon page
it's been overwhelming just how many
people have jumped on over there
hopefully you've been enjoying all the
extra content and the reason why i
really want to thank you guys because
i've been talking
with uh late to the party as well i
don't know if you guys saw that video i
did where i talked about how we got a
ridiculous claim over that tom cruise
video
well those same companies have been
claiming cobra kai reactions
as well and these take a lot of time to
edit it's literally
three in the morning right now i'm
trying to get this unblocked if you're
watching this
i've succeeded and a lot of times we
gotta bite the bullet on just
letting it be visible even if it's not
monetized so what i wanted to say is
like this is actually really common for
every youtuber who does tv show
reactions
so if there is a reactor out there who
covers tv shows
and they have a patreon page try to show
your support if you can't
show your support to all of them share
your support to at least one of them
doesn't have to be
us it can be either one of them i just
wanted to go out there to encourage you
guys to do that just because of the fact
that these do take a lot of time to
actually put together more time than
people realize again
thank you to everyone who has pledged to
our patreon page and checked out all of
our extra content over there the show
is freaking awesome i'm excited to watch
the finale anywho let's swing into
action people
oh the hole filled with cobras damn he
looked around chris there's no rank
damn is cree's gonna fight him probably
that would be the worst case scenario is
this based in some type of reality
like oh i mean i wouldn't be surprised
yeah i
i actually am not informed that if they
did stuff like this back then
cobra car always a fun show
[Laughter]
oh no you're already just like this is
gonna be bad daniel with an l
flashback yeah well there's no more
sneaking around in the kitchen
well there could be you just look hot oh
thank you so do you
that's what johnny and her said each
other exactly what they said to each
other
robbie i mean johnny
johnny yeah johnny this is exactly where
you want to come to
you remember johnny lawrence oh she
she's not up to date on everything huh
no
west valley reunion huh crazy
[Music]
is that made of velvet you sleep in that
uh you should talk their
starface
you can't call me penis breath only they
can call me penis
solid point hey [ __ ] oh damn
by merging with eagle thing weird name
by the way
can keep us all from getting [ __ ] on
anymore then we'd all be [ __ ] not to
do it
all right we'll join well just like that
they've joined him this really is
dimitri where'd it go your daughter hit
his car
you drew a dick on his face your cousin
set his crown fire
that's the recap right there let me
plants
together spent all day together almost
kissed
together so you finally figured out
facebook would you take night classes in
computer literacy
many hours
i just stepped in something didn't
bet you're psyched about this
i was thinking the same thing is that a
positive or have the man boy still doing
on the whole mortal animated
[Laughter]
snacks and sensei dispute resolution
protocol nice
nice oh you think your cow wants to come
in is that a real cat
i think we had a cat we don't
[Music]
what the hell what happened what do you
mean what happened
what's okay that is an overreaction guys
is like next level crime [ __ ] that's
jesus christ
you broke and entered and broke property
damaged some kid's body
what the hell is going at the larusso
household hey
god i hate her so much
we've already broken and entered let's
commit murder
oh boy oh boy tracking shot oh boy
[Laughter]
okay so their rivalry wasn't the reason
you and daniel woke up i think i need to
hear it
wasn't she dating a quarterback daniel
sees me talking to my friend he jumps to
conclusions
i told you just like i told you that the
brakes on mr miyagi's car were gonna
first they let ali bar the car and she
redesigns my fender
[Laughter]
both her heads were pretty far up our
asses back then that was so far up there
i could see at my mouth
it took me a second to go where what
kids
are more evolved than we were
[Music]
god jesus he just got out of the
hospital dude
ugh dude
this is so bad they are sadistic
and masochistic oh my god this is so big
man oh these windows are all to go
all serious this is directed really cool
though yeah
daredevil fighter this season oh dude
oh
wow dude
he's like a video game oh my god
oh [ __ ] here we go this sounds like
sammy now
damn it dude miguel's getting his come
on sam you got this oh
no sam no so she really running she's
putting on her miyagi doe outfit yeah
that's right
she's gonna drive the car right in the
front door if you're worried about
miguel's back
you have every right to be right now
whoa now this is the drive fight
come on sam got this oh wow
it's all right guys tori has a rough
life at home so this is all justifiable
there's your side and your side
and the truth you recognize parts of
yourselves in each other and maybe you
don't always like what you see
[Music]
that's why she came back here she likes
what she sees in both of them
part of all of this is my small part i'm
so happy i got to see you
oh and amanda yeah oh yeah her oh my
oh my wife had so many love interests
they're just coming back
two exes one season the way things ended
with us we were so young
good times far outweighed the bed
leave johnny for me
what just happened oh what just happened
that was a modicum of respect we just
witnessed let's go home and get into
some trouble
ah you have no idea
hack okay i hate her i hate her
oh you know what you're the only one
[Music]
no one else punch her in the vagina
yes yeah yes fish fish pull fish
whatever it's called cast a line there
yeah that's one gossip you don't see any
num chuck fights these days
no ah god how how is miguel still
standing
no he's just correct he's destroying his
spine
what he's having to change at heart
right now it's a little sudden
oh that's interesting be strong for the
week hawk
actually there's something about this i
really like all this
first i was like i don't know about this
there's something kind of really human
about that split second change
wow what the hell oh my god
i mean he could just as easily change
those videos
yeah oh
boom
my god dude
but it's working
that looks so painful
oh
[Music]
ugh
how is he standing i don't know
yes this will never be over so you hear
me
you know where to find me i'm clearly
happy
until you go into witness protection
dude the fact that miguel
won shows how much of a badass he is hey
yeah because he's just just an episode
ago he couldn't kick
you know he's done it with very little
spine
so who is this hot lady i hear you
she's uh she's amazing well she's cool
enough to make johnny lawrence
speechless
you better figure it out quick it's like
i told you i would screw these things up
well you didn't screw up today thanks
for making me feel like a kid again
everything she says just sounds so
sexual it's
really annoying it's true
i can't live in the past you can't live
in the past
i know you're gonna be happy i know
you'll be happy too
it's like a love spar
oh he had a little head thing it looked
like he was about to kiss her
i needed this oh
so worried all this time i know
crap ally's going to be the villain in
the next season she's going to she's
going to kill carmen it's going to turn
out
dead and she just came back as an angel
to help out
oh miguel's injured though i love you
i love you oh she's gonna be so pissed
what's wrong
oh this is no bueno
[ __ ] i gotta fight chris
it's definitely going to be the
commanding officer that girlfriend
is back home what's her name she's dead
oh
you monster sick i didn't want you to
lose focus
so much for that idea well you just gave
him all the motivation he needs now yeah
not only did you give him despair but
you let him hate you
is it cobras underneath like a bunch of
snakes gotta be that's partly probably
why
he uses them the true origins of cobra
kai
that's even worse than i imagined no no
no no no
oh i feel like climbing around my balls
i'm not even sure it's like tingles
enough to make anybody feel like indiana
jones
oh here we go come on jody oh we're
gonna have one of those cool cut back
and forth things
oh i forgot about robbie
to him dead oh robbie what's what's best
for you
oh robbie i
i mean you it's a weird thing for you to
be saying
get him get him get him yes johnny come
on
get him come on johnny please don't let
this be a fantasy
this episode has been non-stop action
oh no
oh damn
oh get him get him come on
johnny [ __ ] dude
oh my goodness
oh
oh no oh robbie
only tell only defense oh
robbie
oh you oh my god he would
of course he would god damn it daniel
where are you
oh man he is just reliving his trauma
isn't it
god damn all the time
oh my god danny where are you
huh
wow
jesus
danny you better show the [ __ ] up right
now
it's an illegal hold
[Music]
yes
oh man this episode is crazy
ah
[Music]
oh my god
we were just uh just about to honk his
his nose
away from our kids why don't we settle
this the old fashioned way feel like you
have
what we've been doing
but you don't respect rules i go
if you lose we won't lose
[Music]
we won't lose hear that we won't lose
oh you gotta be [ __ ] me get out of
here oh you gotta be [ __ ] me
robbie i just started truly loving you
this season
damn it come on son
oh crease you prick
[Music]
i hate chris so much
[Music]
season four
i wonder
oh man they've done it haven't they
look to your right now hmm
yes
oh my god it's finally happening
yes oh [ __ ]
oh my gosh it's
finally happened i can't believe it
i'm so happy
no way
oh
oh i got a little tears in my eyes
oh boy this is going to be impossible to
edit
footage under 10 minutes and without
popular music
oh god oh boy there was so much action
yeah that was like a nonce they cut to
the country club
a few times but otherwise it was just
ass kick there's
so much and they threw down on the one
shots that crazy one shot inside of
larusso's home when they all
showed up yeah this was just so
i'm just so non-stop i'm drained
it's crazy how like you know we've
talked every episode about
themes and a theme that seemed to be
very prevalent that it's been here since
the start of season one but
especially this one with having crease
in here is living in the past
not truly absolving yourself of your
past traumas
and then here you see with crease a real
detailed out from exploring his
flashbacks
there's a thing in psychology i believe
the psychological term is called
recreation
where it's like you don't do those steps
to get over it
sounds really something that's how it's
so simple number one get over your
trauma all right
you haven't processed still there
it's something that can be so buried
within and that you find ways
of recreating that and and you know like
this is like the
very physical example of what he's doing
here like mirroring the fight between
the time when ko
we've got the idea hey snakes cope
clearly that is such a core moon memory
for him when he fought his colonel yeah
i think
would he fight his colonel i was wrong
he's the captain not the colonel oh god
what am i doing
finding out about the death of the woman
he loved and then you're cutting back
and forth showing how it's mirroring
that that moment you know and then even
with robbie the son the person he's
he's saved like it's just all this just
giant
traumatic thing that has all been
recreated and because of this guy
all of this it's like it all goes back
to crease it all goes back
to this core memory this core wound and
it's cool how they kind of
dealt with both sides of it because you
got the core wound of
crease and how that's stemmed all the
cobra ca
and the rivalry but then you even have
the thing with ally of how
a lot of that started with johnny and
danny from
that point so the core wounds of all
these different
elements everyone's cores are just
coming out
yeah and how it's all just recreated now
led to the growth here with johnny and
danny
having to put the past behind them and
have to move forward in the future
i think that's really cool again i've
talked about this many times
this show knows how to handle legacy not
pure nostalgia not just only nostalgia
and hey remember that
they know how to handle legacy and this
was just a great example because
yeah there's so much kick-ass action in
here at the same time though like wow
they really know how to let them
the story go forward uh in in such
mesmerizing ways how do you feel about
the hawk thing i'm kind of conflicted on
that
i'm i'm a little back and forth the
parts i really love about it there are
parts i'm kind of like
i don't know yeah i i'm kind of with you
on that wavelength i mean right now
just as the episode has ended i i think
i'm probably more to the positive side
than not just because it was
so gratifying and yeah they have been
playing all of his sort of more human
moments
just as expressions for the most part
this season so a look
yeah i literally turn i feel a little
bad every episode there's a there's a
hawk look
yeah and and i guess to me what that
scene
communicated was sort of he's looking
around surveying this and now it's clear
that where cobra kai starts and anyone
else begins has become very muddied
because of all the people they've lost
this season who are also in this fight
now so i think it was one of those
things where it's like
oh he's in cobra kai we've seen him
again have his alpha status challenge
time and again
whether it be like kyler which wasn't a
big deal but then you got robbie who
seems like he's you know chris's new
favorite
for you know manipulative reasons and so
yeah having him
look around this whole fight i it did
read authentically to me but i could see
how
it might not to somebody it just seemed
like it's a cacophony it's like a
crescendo of chaos and then he's like oh
man
even people like a week ago who are my
allies now i'm
i'm fighting like this is so ugly and
it's such carnage and everything and i
think too
because he cared so much about miguel
and every one of his
spats with crease has been about like
you're bringing robbie in he's the one
who broke miguel's back like he's the
enemy
he's clearly kind of i think been pushed
also
sort of actively toward considering
these other people
and not only considering cobra kai i
think i would have liked to have spent a
little bit more
real time with him in some real
emotional moments because i can see how
there could be a debate a little bit
about his redemption moment
because he does kind of just like his
first appearance even in this episode he
just shows up and just starts thrashing
[ __ ] and fighting come on [ __ ] get like
[ __ ] like that we're watching so much
happen then it's just kind of this split
moment
that's the back and forth side of me of
that's kind of how life can work
sometimes i thought this show is always
based in the
realistic realities but that's kind of
how life can work sometimes
realizations can kind of hit you in the
blink of an eye as opposed to
you know constant scenes and dialogue
that okay i'll change my mind you know
yeah and i mean i i was expecting him to
have like a big
cry scene or something this season which
which we
didn't get but i think one of the other
things that hit me during that whole
house fight is this is the most extreme
in terms of crime
like they broke into the zoo they saw a
snake that's a crime but you know
they're sneaking around and they're
doing hooligan [ __ ] whereas this like
they've broken in they threw a kid
through the window like it's not in
public anymore like they're literally
destroying a home
so not that i necessarily think that
just explains it away but i think it is
also like
we've reached a caliber where
something's gonna come of
this whole scenario no matter like they
can't have gone in there without
expecting retaliation
i mean it's not my main takeaway of this
episode it felt like it was
going to happen at some point so i guess
that's why i can
handle that even though i don't find it
to be the smoothest fleshed-out
execution
of hawk getting to this point it's not
really a detriment for me i know that
whoever disagrees with me that's going
to be your comments
all right i could do a gazillion things
i talk about 99 of
amazing things and the second i talk
about that that's all you're going to
say in your comment boxes
all right so you can say whatever you
want i think that
everything else outside of that i have
no questions about i actually really
thought uh
everything else was 100 well executed
sam overcoming her trauma and like i
love when they bring those things back
the thing is when it comes up you don't
really expect it in that moment
like with sam uh having to face tori and
how she gets that reminder of her
lessons with danny
and when danny is fighting crease and
it's like when that moment happened
with uh you know remove their ability to
wage war in the moment when that episode
occurred
uh episode five i think we were both
like oh you could use that on crease you
probably will
but in the moment here i just didn't
even cross my mind it didn't even
cross my mind when that happened yeah so
they know how to get you so wrapped in
the moment of it all that's like you
want danny to show up to help out with
johnny
you're like willy woody i don't really
know yet i feel like he will
and then when he shows up it's still so
like this episode does a such a great
job and i feel like the show in general
does a great job on
things that you're expecting or
predicting to happen when they happen
they're still
exceptionally rewarding and then they
still know how to get you so pulled in
that you forget about things you weren't
expecting to happen
you know yeah they're really good at
earning things and they're really good
at using
heart to guide yeah the heart and legacy
and and the themes and the themes yeah
like there
it is i think solid writing because
nothing seems to happen flippantly or
because we
want it to and everything you know is
gonna happen seems to take a pretty
logical minus yeah like
talking about hawk maybe not but most
things seem to take a pretty
reasonable road like johnny and danny's
redemption or at least you know alliance
has been
three seasons in the making and it's
like oh you needed this sort of like
intermediary person and i never would
have guessed that elizabeth shu's
presence might have had that effect but
i love that's where it all began
yeah that's what i mean by the core
right yeah you go to the core wound and
then this is where it all resolves
yeah i think that's great really
beautifully done yeah yeah so they have
like a really good psychological handle
i think that's why i prefer the show
over the
over the movies it's because the show
you really get more time to flush out
the characters and to really explore
them from like a more
psychological angle as they've clearly
done
you know it seems to be such a prevalent
thing to do with this series but yeah i
think
ally's presence coming back was great i
loved the whole scene
at that uh charity event i like when
they used the other characters outside
of the world of johnny and danny
yeah to be like isn't this ridiculous
yeah it's just guys in their karate
put you so much into the perspective of
johnny and danny that it's nice to get
the outside perspective of like have you
heard about this ridiculous rival that
they had going on
yeah and the way they they handled all
of that right down to
the fact that ali respected the fact
that johnny um
actually is really interested in someone
else and johnny did talk about how he
tends to sabotage things
screw things up and he came this close
to completely sabotaging it with carmen
whose name i now remembered
because ali brought it up that's right
thank you all
thank you ali you have solved so many
that moment of talking about like it's
time to let the past go
i love how much they again using legacy
not just nostalgia because she could
have easily just been some easter egg
fun character to bring back
but they used her to truly drive these
characters plots
forward and to put a resolve on things
because yeah when she's not a karate kid
too
it is sequel replace girl thing you know
i don't really know the ins and outs of
why elizabeth's shoe wasn't back i don't
know if it's because like oh we didn't
care to bring her back or taking danny
to japan
or she didn't want to come back i don't
i i've never looked it up so i have no
idea
but it does feel like oh part two
girlfriend not in it
yeah so i like how they actually filled
in that gap
you know like what really happened here
to even flesh out more of the backstory
and
fill in some blanks between karate kid
one and two i thought was really cool to
do because all you really get is like
she's talking with some quarterback or
something like that yeah i forget
exactly what it was a friend
oh i thought you were in love with him
and when they were talking about the
brakes on the car was that the thing
that danny was getting miyagi to fix at
the beginning of karate kid 2. i think
so is that what she was referring to
probably i couldn't i didn't remember
the details of what happened with the
car for
karate kid2 so i felt like that might
have been what they were alluding to
i wouldn't put it past him you gotta
have at least a couple just easter eggs
everything she says seems so sexual she
is she really
shows everything she says just sounds
sexual she really recaptured
yeah that bouncy like very just like
sort of bubbly and into
like whatever she's talking about at the
time like she really just looked like
she was enjoying
every moment who's carmen oh yeah so you
like him she's like
this sounds like it even turns you off
girl yeah it's interesting to see that
like she hasn't lost that charm
not at all this is some of the best
fighting the
series has ever provided that tracking
shot was not only just a really well
choreographed
so i got to give credit to all the
actors too because a lot of these actors
didn't have martial arts training until
this show so to see where a lot of them
have come
that's pretty great one thing i probably
would have liked to actually you know
what not i think about not
like they had so much focus in this
final fight
of kyler fighting with miguel like that
was the big thing
and i didn't really feel like it was
building to that and that's became like
the main focus for what mcgill's fight
was if anything i thought it was
building to miguel and hawk fighting
with each other so i was like i would
have liked a little bit more build up
but then again
it wasn't really about miguel and kyler
it was about miguel
having that faith in himself again
because he started off at the beginning
of the season as someone who's i'm
injured i'll never be able to get back
to where i
am he's constantly feeling a little down
on himself even when he's like fighting
to get back to where he once was
he doesn't really believe he's capable
of doing it and then here you get to the
scene where
as much as he's getting his spine
thrashed in yes unrealistic whatever
it's [ __ ] awesome okay it's cool
all your vertebrates down there are
putty now they're just a paste
right he would have been in a gurney by
the time he showed johnny's show back up
at carmen's it would have been a
freaking ice back on his head he would
have been like
you should back it off back in a coma
but it did make me think of the you know
speech they give to the
board you know to get the all valley
tournament back on and going back like
as much as it would make sense for
miguel and hawk to fight as sort of like
the alphas of
karate organizations now it's like we do
have that history with kyler and i'm
sure that like when he came into
kobrakai he started trying to push hawk
around because it's that old dynamic
that he thought he could rest on
not the case and so there it made sense
to me at least that yeah that would come
back around it didn't feel as much of
like a oh damn they tied it together but
it did feel like a okay
now that chapter's closed yeah you know
i mean with hawking dimitri which is a
history
like sometimes doesn't really come to
mind when i think about these characters
but i thought that was actually neat it
didn't go down that route that i think a
lot of us thought it would go where
miguel and hawks were off they instead
used this final fight to deal with
miguel's personal journey
finding that faith within himself again
and then using
that moment with hawk to have a resolve
with dimitri
because demetri and hawker are kind of
like when i joined network marketing and
john joy network marketing and then john
didn't go down the same path
i did and i got really extreme about
network marketing
and then all you know the [ __ ]
friends came and broke my arm
yeah man you were vitamin high i just
couldn't i couldn't stop myself man
okay but then we teamed back up and we
kicked ass together
yeah so that's how that's how it goes
you know so it's a real reflection of
john and i and um this show is a real
biography of us
uh what else happened hate tori excited
like
trying to keep the discussions of things
that are obviously not communicated in
the reaction
i liked what they did with sam
ultimately because that had me going for
a minute i figured that she would
ultimately have to rise to the occasion
but in the moment i was like oh damn
she's actually gonna run away for a
second and she needs to find it i like
that they make things not quite so clean
because i feel like in a different show
it might have been like
secondary steps up then she calls upon
her wisdom from dad whereas it had to
take a moment to build herself back up
to that
this is a really great like i heard that
they had three and four mapped out
before season three came out i'm like
jesus christ guys really
how much can you do and then you get to
the end of
season three and you're like oh yeah
they didn't even get to the tournament
what yeah great setup for season four of
brilliant
yeah yeah well and then robbie being on
the
cobra kai side oh my god just
talk about that theme with the sins of
the
father are passed down to the sun a plus
is that what it is
sins of the fathers are doomed to be
repeated by the sons they're passed down
to the sons well there you go it's in
the show it's thematically present
sons and daughters i guess
it's there in the series man robbie you
broke my heart dude
yeah sir that yeah it did it makes sense
it
does like we've seen it with this guy
you know if
someone's willing to be a daddy and
hasn't betrayed him yet he's going to be
with him that's his character because if
he's a kid he hasn't had a
father figure like it makes sense from
like a psychological angle
it makes sense but damn from an audience
perspective
it's a real stinger because i was like
just starting to
this was like
and i think that's part of the
brilliance is they broke your heart yeah
they
really endeared us to him and they gave
us like the most
bitter end for that at least for now
because yeah like when johnny's
doing his best to only move defensively
and there's that moment where he
lets him slam against that locker and
both sides of my brain went in different
directions one apart was like
yes and the other part was like oh god
no this is the last thing you wanted to
do
because this is gonna make everything
way worse like robbie's always
had a bit of a cobra kai in him
obviously i mean you think about it like
even at the end of season two he was
part of miyagi dough and then he ends up
being the one who retaliates and breaks
miguel's back
so it seemed like it was bound to go
this way it seemed to be the only place
he could end up for the season that
wouldn't be too easy
yeah you know it's like he's not going
to come right back around to johnny or
dan
especially not danny it's such a
surprising season because it seems like
it's ramping up to like a crazy 15
minutes of a finale
yeah yeah it seems like that's where
it's going and then 10 minutes into this
it's like
oh we're non-stop right now broken
yeah it's like you come back to the
country club to get a couple warm and
fuzzies but for the most part everything
is either yeah
creases culmination his loss of humanity
and then just the horrible [ __ ] show of
the current valley karate scene it just
does not stop nonstop it was like so
rewarding to watch them fight against
crease yeah
to find a common enemy i would
occasionally
occasionally this is a nitpick but why
not throw a nitpick in here
i've occasionally pulled that one it's
really obvious that there was a stunt
double for chris
there's there's a lot of like put it
behind him whenever his face feels like
that's obviously not great yeah yeah
yeah
all right it's a nitpick but things like
that from like watching fight scenes can
sometimes pull me out of out of the
moment yeah but i i do
think because i think generally across
the show usually the
the kids fight scenes move and breathe a
little more
fluidly naturally than some of the adult
ones i did think that
despite some of those moments like in
that dojo fight at cobra kai like
especially uh william zobko like got
some good looking moves
in you know doesn't he have like an
actual history with martial arts
it would make sense but i don't know i
feel like he does like he's one of the
producers of the show and i think a big
part of the
conception of this series had to do with
him yeah that would make a lot of sense
but yeah they're teamed up
finally can't wait to watch them butt
heads all season four and how to train
their kids
yeah find out who gets to be number one
lesson plan
to see them not get along and learn to
work together can't wait to see what
nicknames these kids get under both
it's exciting for them to come together
but you also know that's going to come
with a lot
of tension doesn't mean the tension's
resolved doesn't mean it's just going to
be
you know like smooth as hell there's
going to be conflicts that come
up and so i'm i'm interested to see how
that all progresses
and i'm excited for the five students at
cobra kai yeah
tory robbie and then three others
oh and well and they'll have romance
next season i'm sure oh yeah i was
wondering is that the
the person he was calling who's the guy
karate kid three oh the ponytail guy who
like runs the
karate corporation silver is his name
something like that
yeah i think let me look it up real fast
hillary swank yeah silver
terry silver it's been a long time since
i've seen karate kid 3 but i remember
pretty well i remember like especially
the fight where
miyagi beats him up and kicks him into
the mirror at the end it was pretty cool
that's a crease heavy movie too i think
that would would be
the villain from karate kid the main
film from karate kid 3 who
starts to influence danny bringing
everybody back
yeah we're going to bring everyone back
when
if they don't bring hillary swank then
i'm gonna be upset
because he was a vietnam war comrade i'm
pretty sure that's him
it would be the most exciting thing to
do
yeah plus plus just to watch how they've
deal with and fit karate kid 3 into the
current
chronology and everything just because
like karate kid 3 is
probably the wackiest one in some ways
so i feel like they would have some
stretching to do to
you know bring things down to the to the
ground i love karate kid three when i
was a little kid
so that that's then you're correct
you're absolutely correct
it's a wonderful pg movie and it's great
all right guys well karate kid i mean a
cobra guy
cobra kai season three
what'd you guys think where would you
rank this season
man that was a lot yeah i
i feel cathars this is a very thick
episode
i need time for it to settle in but a
minute wasted my god
i wonder if they can go two more seasons
but i feel like one more is pretty solid
yeah leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit the like button
hopefully we got this up successfully on
youtube
see you guys
you